uh
[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another episode of honest trailer
commentaries today's film doctor strange
two in the multiverse of madness we're
gonna be giving you all our behind the
scenes thoughts uh show you some deleted
scenes and
answer viewer comments and questions
keep those coming in the chat it will
tease you with next week's honest
trailer
it's long um also strange straight yeah
strange and long long
uh anyways yeah there's a little preview
um doctor strange two uh was a film and
it's one that i enjoyed more as a movie
than as an installment of the mcu season
4 episode 7 or whatever yeah i think
that which has i think pros and cons
like i don't feel like this was good in
terms of character continuity or
deepening characters that i either cared
about or didn't i don't think it did
anything for me going forward with
either stranger wanda or america or any
one of that
but we were talking beforehand like the
third act super fun sam raimi's doing uh
doing his thing with a huge budget and
uh it was definitely entertaining more
entertaining to me as a standalone film
when i think about it in terms of the
mcunis of it all i think its weaknesses
start to show whether that matters to
you your mileage may vary what do you
think daniel i mean no i think it's fun
like i said uh there are a lot of
obviously there's the fun of all of the
multiverse stuff you get in that moment
where you hear the uh x-men animated
theme
music and immediately just like oh this
is the most excited i felt in my entire
life um i'm broken and so but you know
you have those little moments and and
you know you got in your black bolt
actually uh being worth something some
redemption for black bolt i'm not going
to pretend like i watched in humans
i watched the first episode but
anson mount is is a delight he's yeah he
played black belt he's now the e captain
pike on strange new world so nice to see
him getting getting a redemptive moment
yeah it is nice but uh yeah no i really
fun movie i also really love the
raininess in it and i agree i think
because as soon as i start putting it
into
like the mcu of it all that's when it
starts to be like well but isn't this a
conflict we already kind of resolved
well didn't we kind of already do this
before like it just feels like retreads
of of like other things that have
already happened
um i would have liked to more if sam
raymond was like i have a new movie it's
called magic man versus witch lady
oh did you see magic man for switch lady
it was it was awesome i watched that i
don't know why the fantastic four was in
it but it was
badass
uh longwood yeah i mean i'm mostly in
agreement i think it narratively this
one's a real mess it it doesn't sort of
like it's got to real like this leads to
that leads to that problem where things
don't logically sort of seem to follow
and a lot of i think the character
motivations are a little screwy and and
i think they they do a real disservice
to america chavez as a character we
really don't get to she's important to
the story but only because of what she
could do not because of who she is we
don't really get to know her at all and
i think that's a big downside having
said all of that uh once the third act
kicks in like everything from wanda
arriving at illuminati hq and kicking
ass there through the end is so good
it's so cool it just feels like
stylistically very much like a meeting
of raymie doing what he does in the mcu
as a sort of storytelling platform or
whatever i really like all that stuff so
much that i almost am willing to forgive
everything else like i don't watch these
movies for
the
you know relatable human like i i guess
that's part of it that i don't i don't
think of the mcu as like well this is
going to touch my soul with its relevant
statements about what it is to be human
in the world like there's other movies
for that these are
these are corpse guys going to make a
cape out of those ghosts i'm like yeah
man that sounds awesome like ghost tape
that's what i want from the mcu is is
you know ghost cape which that's fair
but i do think i do think in the past
they've been better at at um balancing
that not even balancing it but they've
had more compelling characters than
doctor strange i'm not arguing that with
you that's obviously true i think there
are movies that are more successful at
being more like a real movie that works
like a real story and has the mcu-ness
of it for sure
i'm just saying
it doesn't bother me when they don't do
one of those things if they do the other
one really well all right well let's see
which one they did in this here honest
trailer roll it
partner
after avengers end game broke the
multiverse one division broke the
multiverse oh god you don't know what
you've done what if broke the multiverse
loki broke the multiverse spider-man
broke
you see where i'm going with this
dr strange will break the multiverse
again in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
get ready for a spooktacular sequel
full of gore that would shock a 13 year
old raised without internet
scary monsters like uh bees
so pause
we can talk about amer uh america at
this point just america
good god i don't want to talk about this
country but the character of america um
it does seem like a dropped plot thread
or a missed opportunity to me if you
introduce a character who
hops
universes every time she gets scared and
then you put her in a horror movie but
the only time she gets scared in hops
universes is when a bee lands on her
finger
she seemed like you could build a
compelling thing where plot and
character were kind of working together
where it's like we have to keep this
girl from getting scared or teacher to
control her fear what is she afraid of
what she uh
let's get more into how she works as a
human being but it's just like kind of
waved away you're saying i missed the
line but there's some line where dr
strange is like you could always control
i don't know why
almost at the very end uh when he's
trying to say like you know you can open
a portal
where you need to he's basically telling
her like you you've always was inside
you've always been in control of your
powers and she doesn't believe him and
he's like because you you brought us to
whatever universe we need to go to so
like without even realizing it she
brought them to the illuminati universe
and then she knew she even showed up at
that dr strange's universe and then
she's got another line where she goes
yeah but what about that b who scared me
and then i blasted my moms to another
universe
i just assumed that they had my girl in
her universe
not the bees get the coley cool
uh no like i think he's got this very
strange line where it's basically like
ah yes but even that brought you here to
where you needed to be so like your
mom's had to die in that horrible bee
accident so that you could become the
american chavez that saved the universe
it just seemed like an easy win or an
easy way to
work more character development into a
quasi-horror movie is that you set up
somebody whose powers are controlled by
fear and then you just leave that it's
just but i don't i don't think her
powers are controlled by fear i think
that's the like the that's what happened
when she was a child and now she's like
developing
this ability to like i don't know it's
it's very vague but i i mean to me the
whole thing comes back to it's really
her it should be her story this is her
story it's about the witches after her
not doctor straight doctor strange is
the ally who comes in and helps her yeah
but i think by making this dr strange's
story instead of america we kind of do
the whole story of disservice in a real
way we'll get we'll get to him let's uh
let's keep watching
oh
crap
not again no
13 year old
that marvel doesn't know what to do with
the x-men or fantastic four
should we be concerned i'm kind of
starting to get concerned boner
and we'll talk about this more later
homeopathic iron man returns and no
matter what he says i'm happy he's sad
now i am happy
you're not feeling anybody
catch up with the sorcerer supremes
regional assistant manager who was once
as strong as thanos but lately is weaker
than math math and watch history
continue
as he's outworked by his own cave
easily my favorite character
tries to make ray chap in it was never
gonna work out between us it's not gonna
happen i love you in every universe
i do love how he's constantly being
nagged by his own franchise that's kind
of funny yeah i guess so doctor strange
i mean
he's
doing the same thing that he was doing
in doctor strange one uh
which is pining after
christmas she's not night nurse yeah
christine
uh she's a doctor christina
he's just doing that again like that's
his arc is like you need to
sort of give up on pining after your ex
right
and and be happy with being
single like what what is doctor
strange's he's an independent man in the
90s he don't need no woman yeah in this
film
why are we seeing his
watch
yeah
why is
this gotta get that watch fix that's the
sign that you're healthy again yeah i
just don't care by the way uh funny
watch fact um that's a
25 000 watch that she gifts him and he
and she talks about how like he's too
broke from student loan to pay for
dinner like maybe give him the give him
the check
instead of the 25 grand watch that's it
expect him to hang on to that i'm
honestly not sure if until this moment i
knew there was a twenty five thousand
dollar one that seems too expensive for
one watch like what else do you get with
that
nothing it's like it's gold it's like on
a disney cruise they bring you the watch
but it's in one of those star wars
containers that opens all fans yeah yeah
so
uh yeah dr strange just completely to me
i guess what i'm getting at is he is a
completely uncompelling character to me
and he's best used as kind of a
uh quip exposition machine in other
people's movies and i really don't care
about this mcu version of them i do not
care about it's not that i don't care
for her but i don't i don't care about
him in uh these two solo movies i always
prefer doctor strange
he literally
always always better in other people's
movies than in his movie because like
his
you know i get it uh you know really sad
arrogant dude turns on arrogant uh saves
the world blah blah blah you know the
full ironman whatever it's fine but
they haven't i i don't care about
christine
there's nothing they've done nothing to
make me care about christine i will
honestly i want more wong always
sure always
baby and he's also
all up and everywhere like he's he's
there he's their journeyman cameo
yeah yeah he's uh yeah he's cage
fighting in uh shanghai yeah and then
karaoke and then karaoke yeah right um
yeah so i just
i don't know the the
i understand
to like it always seems like the doctor
strange movies are just setting up other
stuff like it's a pivot point for other
things and so i usually tend to look at
them like at that where it's like yeah
you know once end game was done you go
back and you look at the original doctor
strange you're like okay i see how this
fits in um and so i feel like when it
comes to his character maybe later
it'll be like okay i see what we did in
doctor strange too but i i haven't
gotten what that is yeah yeah i mean to
me it it it sort of does come back to
like well this doesn't really feel like
it's his story so it is like i don't
know what he's supposed to be like
learning from this experience other than
yeah he like he he's cut he's the
universal cuck
like he gets cucked by rachel mcadams in
every unit in every universe
but like yeah i i just i really do feel
like the way that this whole movie is
sort of conceived in this whole story
works there's this really awkward like
the main character's kind of not the
main character and the movie never kind
of figures out how to split that
difference and it only stops bothering
me once it's like doesn't matter anymore
because it's the third act and it's just
like which fight yep which fight 2022
agreed oh that goo doctor strange three
uh seven movies later yeah but i mean
the set pieces to me like what we're not
getting into is like this people make
all this like not matter like once wanda
shows up at uh comartaj and starts like
laying waste to the entire city i don't
care that i don't get to know anybody
better right i'm just like oh this is
awesome well and that's i made the goof
fight joke but this is i think that
they some of the most creative battle
stuff that they have done has been in
this because it wasn't just two people
flinging goo with each other that was a
little of that there was some of it but
not goo but more like like magic lasers
yeah some but i mean when like it's no
comparison to the other mcu stuff where
or even we were talking talk about
wizarding world where you know the the
fights are like
they're just like doing this over guns
there's never and i don't mean to like
kick harry potter's ass i like the harry
potter movies but there's there's no
fight in any of the potter films that's
as clever as the musical note battle in
this like there's not a single usage of
magic in a fight in any of those potter
films that approaches the cleverness of
some of these magical fights i'd agree
with that um turns out there's multiple
ways to evaluate a film and your
enjoyment of it they aren't all just
thumbs up thumbs down uh overall that's
crazy i hate when people are like oh
yeah like what give me your five star
ratings like i can't possibly do that
yeah i can't do a five star i can't do a
one out of ten i can't do any of that
stuff i can do a very long boring
nuanced conversation
[Music]
when they pick like two movies and they
have to like fight like this one keeps
getting put up against everything
everywhere all at once because they're
both like i don't know multiverse is a
thing in them and it's like they're not
similar you don't have to compare them
stick around to the end of the tree
doctor strange movies are avengers 3
spider-man 3 and 4-3
welcome back franchise favorites like
wong
and okay basically just wong i baron
who which is why marvel had to call
their mommy i'm a mother when you last
saw her wanda maximov was trapped in
classic sitcoms working her way through
complex emotions like grief and
acceptance
now her character is trapped in a
hallmark movie working her way through
questions like women do be acting crazy
though sometimes right fellas
watch the scarlet witch
movie fight do women be out there
sub question do they be shopping
okay we're not actually a movie fighting
that um no but uh i i'm out yeah as a as
far as the wanda of it all
look i don't really again i i i care but
i don't i i care because uh i think that
they are kind of reversing course and
continuity that they actually built up
very well in wand division and actually
developed the character
i don't care because it's just cool to
have like an arch villain
in a marvel movie that can really just
snap a lot of necks and be yeah fun and
evil but uh i feel like there was a way
where they could have had their cake and
eat it too
and i think that that was just be like
she's just trying to save her kids find
some way for her to save her children
rather than kill her alternate mom and
and steal children and then i think
you're like okay i can see how someone
would want to do that like maybe there's
some alternate dimension where
doctor strange killed her and she's like
all the kids are all alone and they need
her help so she like really needs to get
to them instead of just like
kids would be nice i'm gonna murder
myself and raise them like that it
seemed like a bridge too far where they
didn't even need to go there with her
i mean i will say stealing someone
else's kids is a witch thing like that
is which [ __ ]
that is but it's her own it's her own
self yeah it's her own self it's i mean
people love hocus pocus they're trying
to eat kids
they're literal cannibals yeah oh gosh
that's yeah no the sanders and sisters
are cannibals folks they're trying to
eat children
we've glossed over this for too long
women be
do be crazy sometimes they do be eating
children yeah i um
yeah with wanda because i do i i am such
a sucker for like um
good guy turns bad bad guy turns good
blah blah blah you're a wrestling fan
yeah of course like that's totally
skills and face turns it's my whole
thing um but so but i agree like it felt
like we did we had like a whole series
where we kind of unpacked all of this
and like she looked like she started to
work through it and then someone gave
her a book and it was like book great
i don't i think part of the problem is
that juan division talked a lot about
grief and trauma but i don't know if it
really got like there wasn't really a
lot of development there she ends up
that series basically the same place
where she started where she's
overwhelmed with grief about this lost
it was lost vision and now it's lost
vision and family that she could have
had and except now she's got access to a
lot more power i'm not necessarily
saying like this is a totally natural
seamless character transition like i
agree it seems very big all of a sudden
when she's not been a character making
those kinds of big decisions in the past
having said that after like 10 movies of
elizabeth olsen sitting in a bedroom
being like i don't know i love vision
i know you want to make some paprika i'm
sad about my childhood i was so
delighted to see her get to do a big
comic book crazy villain role yeah and
she's having so much fun i think it's a
really fun performance and i'm like i
like this wanda better like i don't care
that it doesn't link up to the old other
because the old wanda was kind of boring
and this wanda feels like she's coming
to her own and she's very sad using her
powers in a way that is cool and
cinematic and she's scary in it yeah
i guess i just thought that there was a
easy way for her to uh justify that to
herself slash the audience more so than
like well off camera i heard i heard my
kids and now i'm evil i mean like like
the i don't i mean i guess i think i
think the more rational the less
maniacal it might almost be less fun
like the maniacalness is part of what
makes this fun again good standalone uh
uh plot but uh mcu yeah she's like she's
really going for it like he's really
making her like a horror movie villain
in this and it kind of rules all right
let's keep going
off camera and try to burn down the
multiverse in a single-minded search for
her made-up children that she won't shut
up about my children my children i dream
of them my boy for billy and tommy i
just want my boys
why could you just be a normal white
lady and get a rescue dog or save your
dead husband you remember him i blew a
hole through the head of the man i left
[Music]
just once one of the all-time great
comic book legends has returned
sam raimi
watch a director with his own unique
spin on zombie and superhero movies get
asked to you know do that again
but don't worry foggy's still serving up
that sameness you crave full of mcu
comfort slop like commercials for the
next movie if you caused an incursion
then we're gonna fix it
that's
clear
[Laughter]
i knew that
action sequences that look worse than
marvel vs capcom
centrist politics that pair subtle nods
to gay rights with subtle nods to
burning books with naughty words in them
and the latest variant of this
universally hilarious joke there was an
incident with spider-man what man black
agar bolt again hit a guy there the
illumi star-lord who i need you to be
the ant-man is the tool to change the
name a unimine uni
was that a new thing bad guys give
themselves bad names your name is
taserface dr otto octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
gets funnier the more times you hear it
right
god
i guess pause there's nothing more to
add really uh but there were more i
wrote there were 22. yeah i i we cut it
probably in half yeah i i actually went
through it like really thought about
every single time they do that in the
shows and films
it initially was about like a genuine
three minutes of people laughing at
silly names in this world full of silly
names and they should all yeah like they
all right they all have silly like it's
not a weird thing in their world yeah
okay
moving on
explores the limitless possibilities of
the multiverse for one whole scene
really can we go back to paint world for
a sec no okay no i don't know how okay
settle for the mcu's bogus journey
across the multiverse where the
differences are all cosmetic we're going
red the characters barely change you
know you hated me where i came from and
i bet secretly my brother you hated me
here and the plot devices are either
literal convenience stores replay your
significant membership oh man this is
the worst thing
that's the this is the worst beat in the
whole movie that's the worst beat in a
marvel movie i think um that might be
the worst marvel moment for me is two
characters walking down the street in
the future
and we don't know enough about america
yet so of course
there's a store called memory lane
memory lane but they give their product
is they'll show you a movie of your
memories why is this useful you remember
your memories that's why they're your
memories let's let's move on no no we're
not moving on because they say over the
pa um they're now at a discount like
half price or something like that why
would you and yet they just start
playing them when you're on the street
no consent they're
they're they're serving anything there
was no eula oh your mind has been
entered uh by a powerful psychic their
service is showing you your memories but
then they're giving you everyone by the
way to everyone else on the street
because doctor strange is watching it
too they're and why are they picking
traumatizing memory why would you want
to relive the moment you killed your mom
like it would be like your birthday you
want to buy a postcard of your mom's
dying
like obviously get it on a t-shirt it
would be happy memories would be the
purpose of that store right if i lived
near memory lane i would just that would
be where i went for lunch every day just
like ah let's see what dumb stuff this
person did yeah just be like a hundred
percent dude that chick killed her mom's
cause of a bee
[Laughter]
just the
the absolute laziest instead of starting
a conversation or anything this is an
alien planet in another universe uh how
come they're speaking of fluent america
like earth spanish sure well in an
infinite universe one of them speaks
fluent space and they have memories from
the star planet where america exists
somehow
and everyone speaks spanish yeah and
like doctor strange and baron mordo
they're all pretty much the same people
yeah they all ended up in more or less
the same roles doctor strange still
loki's loki's an alligator
somehow loki became an ally just how did
we not get another doctor strange so he
could make out with himself
there's still time there's still time i
mean we've got a lot of other doctor
strangers that just didn't come come to
that yet yeah yeah uh anyway i feel like
ponytail strange is down
[Laughter]
if you got those two in the same
universe i feel like it would especially
if he's like still arrogant doctor
strzok yeah of course
think about the
with a sling ring you know like now
you're thinking with portals
[Laughter]
all right keep going
even main characters like america who
just like her namesake means well
believes a trail of destruction and fast
food wherever she goes preferably pizza
pizza balls so if you only watch one
film this year about a young woman
traveling the multiverse to find their
mother where people learn to project
themselves into their alternate timeline
cells and the poster looks like this
please see everything everywhere all at
once instead i know a lot of you been
asking for an honest trailer for that
one so here it is it's way better than
doctor strange
sorry we have to compare them
that's the thing it's like well i'm just
saying but like this is a comedy video i
mean like in a review sense they could
both be good they could both be bad like
we're always doing that where it's like
if two movies are like similar we gotta
pick which one is the best so this one
beats the hell out of that one yeah well
what it shows you well what it shows me
is that it's not um an idea that you
need the mega budget and mega celebrity
to pull off that's not what makes it a
good concept and what makes it a good
film and what makes you care about the
characters and yeah
it's just the fact that
they put so much more imagination into
the same premise in everything
everywhere thank you i don't i don't i
don't know if i agree they're they're
very different movies i mean i don't i
don't even think they're trying to i'm
not knocking everything just the idea of
the lengthy versus i liked it like two
two uh flavors of basically earth and
the other actually took a look at what
that would be a horror action thing
that's about the spectacle of this like
wizard fight and that one is about like
it's a it's a family dynamic and it's
about the the comedy and the drama of
these characters and the multiverse is
the setting and i i'm not disagree with
you like it's a great movie and it does
use the multiverse in a very clever way
i just like i don't i don't know if it
the comparison doesn't really make a ton
of sense to me they're very very
different all right well lon has recused
himself from the final section of that
on this trailer
comparison like you know we do those
jokes about like how these movies are
kind of similar i don't feel like that's
out of line i just feel like they got
like you know it's always it's it's not
even just these two movies it's any time
there's two movies and they're kind of
similar people always try to do that
like you have to like this one or that
one and it's like no you don't kind of
but in this scenario you can only see
one so true there you go
all right keep going
starring
a quirked up goateed white boy with a
sauce
i think you knew the snickers you're
kind of a witch when you're hungry
citizen starlight
it's more than time
supreme disappointment on the spot
wonderful
the taco was a copy oh yeah he killed
him
the whole universe yeah these are the
terrible sources of screams
fox and friends
mom spaghetti i can do this all day
governor
campbell's lou
a bull as a china cop and
man baby loves his eyeball stuff
so much
doctor strange in one alternate universe
that's basically just the near future
that's honest yeah
dreams of windows into the lives of our
multiversal selves so it's nellie mcu
canon that the dream you had without
seeing your dad naked in the bathtub
really happened sorry
yeah that's an interesting addition for
them to just drop it all dreams are real
all dreams it's just you uh that's
another you it's another another another
universe a lot yeah you're the other you
is showing up naked to class yeah
man he's having this problem
his teeth keep falling
yeah sinking got a lot of anxiety about
falling
the other me is in her room right now
with all the chris all the christmas
goes
for chris you get it out of me yeah
[Laughter]
good times
and not pratt i'm assuming yeah yeah
okay obviously yeah okay um
chris
let's watch some uh oh
thanks for watching like subscribe etc
hit the bell uh hit the
hit everything just press every button
on your on your keyboard at once and see
what happens
and then do check out the phantom twitch
channel uh twitch.tv backslash fandom
where we will be streaming uh games for
now movies later you'll be the judge i
think we're gonna watch jupiter
ascending uh
we gotta do a watch party for that just
for me yeah um so this dress is your
favorite abraxas
[Laughter]
or splice horse place anti-gravity moon
boots
boots yeah grab any dog nope
[Laughter]
yeah we'll do that later and then uh
let's play some deleted scenes if we
have any
we must
dr strange will break the multiverse
again in
doctor strange and the mom
abbreviation starring
char wizard
necromicon
99 problems and a witch is one
death becomes her
all my nexus flinging hexes
remember sliders that was a great show
the wiz
the actual sorcerer supreme the sorcerer
grande
the wong remains the same rachel
girlfriend the boys
the genius bar
not dwight for the roll i love it when
you call me big pizza papa
the wizarding world of scary mother
the plot against america
yeah
uh okay i was worried about that one
because it's a philip roth novel and i
was like our fans don't care about
philip no they don't know that they're
not gonna get that reference but it's
still a funny play on yeah
so um something we didn't talk about
while we were watching but has come up
in the chat so let's let's deal with it
here uh keith p.i uh
writes uh he's a private investor
yeah
my least favorite thing about the film
was that the illuminati a word that
means knowledge we're all stupid uh they
all did really dumb things um and kind
of similarly a lot of people asking us
about the reid richards adam halbert
asking us about reed richards and kind
of all the cameos what did we think
about that moment which was
i think uh again in the mcu a big deal
in this movie just point like they're
just bodies
they are just bodies
hit the floor yes if i let the bodies
hit the floor let the x-men hit the park
i think i think all the cameos are fun
except for krazynski as reid richards
which feels
like pandering it feels like a soft
launch it feels like the internet really
wanted this we're going to give the
internet what it wants oh that was it
there was an interview where feige or um
raymie said like yeah uh feige said that
this is what the internet wants so we're
gonna yeah and let them have a win and
that's that's
make it make a movie don't don't try to
like please me with your you know like i
i hate that sort of like we're to just
deliver what reddit is asking for that's
that's how you get rise of skyway that's
how you get snakes on a plane that's how
you get something right like it's never
even even if you're trying and you're in
in good faith you're making your best
attempt to just do what you think the
fans want you got to do what works for
you and what works for the story and not
what works for the fans so i don't like
that but i i really like a lot of the
other
cameos i think you know seeing patrick
stewart show up is a lot of fun i like
the anson mount thing i like lashana
lynch getting to be captain marvel like
all those i thought were fine i would
have picked some other like more fun i
generally always take captain carter
all day long i don't know how to
pronounce his name the the welsh actor
who plays uh reed richards
yeah the the tim's story reed richards
would have been really funny like that i
would have really enjoyed if you brought
him back that'd have been good um i
genuinely think it would have been a fun
wink towards the fans but also like uh
we know better if they did rain wilson
that's reid richards i think that would
have been amazing yes false you were a
witch
leave the illuminati um oh i would have
lost it that would have been really fun
yeah
uh and then god how terrifying slash
hilarious would it be if you put him on
the the marvel diet and it's like rayne
wilson just jacked walking into her
oiled abs
that's really scary
i don't like that at all i love it i
need it yeah send that send that
photoshop to us please um all right
so on to other questions um did you guys
know that was mike shurer playing moe's
like his the yes dwight's brother is the
the creator of yeah
uh
let's see
um
evan j pretzer asks is the summation of
this next mcu phase going to be edgy and
fix the multiverse like i feel like
let's broaden this question out
is the multiverse just starting or just
ending like how much how many more times
we have to hear this word and have this
be the main focus of a series or film or
can they
kind of tighten it up a little bit going
forward because i really thought well
before we knew that everything was going
to be so multiverse heavy and it was
just this one and it was like okay well
this must be leading up to that and then
we'll start getting more of the
multiverse stuff and maybe doing some
more exploring and yada yada yada i
i can't possibly see if this phase ends
with fantastic four
every movie in this can't be about the
multiverse i do not want to see then i
do not want to see sherry dealing with
the multiverse i don't want it no but
she's cheesy like neymar
yeah yeah i i mean i think
we we know feige has said within the
next few movies we're going to figure
out the next thanos like there is a new
big bad we haven't necessarily met them
yet
maybe maybe not yeah we're going to
figure out who that is in the next few
movies that leads me to believe it's
probably not kang because we already
know that he's going to show up i feel
like galactus that's what i'm thinking
right i feel like i feel like the
multiverse stuff is probably going to
kind of wrap up with the kang uh ant-man
3 movie and that's around the time we're
going to transition into here's the next
thanos level
mcu-wide threat that everybody's going
to have to eventually come back together
and deal with i think galactus or dr
doom would be my top two guesses yeah
they teased incursions too so they're
gonna do the storyline roll the
multiverses collapse until there's
exactly right exactly exactly
i i think multiverse has been the bridge
that's gonna get us to the the next big
bad as opposed to the solution to what
it is sweet okay that'd be my guess
i'm just purely pulling this out of my
butt but feige did say
that we haven't necessarily you know
like at the end of avengers you had that
scene with thanos and that was like
right that's the confirmation that
thanos is the big bad apparent my guess
would be we'll get a post credit scene
like that that'll confirm
i'll be like oh wow who left this silver
surfboard literally something on on that
level or like a person taking a metal
mask out of a flame and like playing
yeah yeah
which is like that's still the dumbest
thing um cut to like a sign welcome to
latveria uh you know and you know what's
going on
all right uh yeah i'm ready for that
because i feel like we're kind of
spinning our wheels here that's also
saying it's gonna involve secret awards
it will involve secrets yeah probably
because they're doing the secret tv show
correct uh yes probably something along
those lines
all right uh a lot of good uh doctor
strange and marvel questions going on
here but there's one i want to uh uh
pull from
[Laughter]
shoreline i was gonna i was gonna do a
different one but okay
here's what's fascinating to me is that
he gets the and you know like at the end
of the credits where everybody else is
able to get benedict wong and rachel
mcadam then you get and michael stewart
he's got once he barely is even in no
reason for him to be in there is that
just like he's got the most amazing
agent yes i think that that he's like
fine i'll do it but yeah i'm assuming
i'm assuming that there was a plan for
him in the in the first one that just
never happened and so they had to bring
him back to be passive aggressive at a
wedding i love him oh man which is
amazing it's so funny that he gets an
and michael's because i did not know he
was going to be in this and so like and
michael stoolbart why they bring him
back and then one scene and you see him
in the beginning and you're like well
obviously this is going to pay off it
doesn't does nothing it's literally just
him being like
oh so i guess did you you for first you
saved the universe wrong
and then you didn't even ask me how i
was at your ex's wedding he's got to
point out that dr strange is a cuck in
every universe that's why he's the best
role that's what he's like you still
didn't get the girl even if you save the
youth let's do it
just why are you here beat it stool bark
well i think surprise toolbar is always
welcome i hope you should i love it in
every movie to berate the heroes for uh
their relationship failures
where do you think we're gonna get a
surprise uh tyler perry
oh that's that's guessing fantastic four
yeah i mean there's a non-zero chance
that he's um
he's the next thor have we met wait have
we met the president of the united
states
[Music]
there's your tyler perry right there
president perry done um he can film it
from his own white house which he owns
yeah oh he's got the oval set has uh
he's got he's got a presidential podium
yeah done
all right well uh
we'll deal with that next week um where
there won't be any surprise uh tyler
perry nor will there be any real
surprises uh if you've seen this before
you've probably
seen it again and seen what's coming
that's also you might fall asleep
because it's so goddamn long
that's your clue for next week uh we
just finished watching now we gotta go
talk and write about it uh but thank you
for watching this episode of honest
trailer commentaries we'll see you then
see ya
[Music]
yeah i like the
steel drums mom
[Music]
foreign